su médico puede recomendar una
hemorroide ctc o mia para extraer sus
hemorroides si no responden a un
tratamiento más conservador las venas
hemorroidales son vasos sanguíneos
dentro de las paredes del recto y del
canal anal las hemorroides también
conocidas como 'la más ramas se
presentan cuando estas venas se hinchan
y el tejido que las rodea se inflama una
vena hinchada cerca de la entrada del
canal anal se denomina hemorroides
externa una vena hinchada dentro del
recto se denomina hemorroide interna las
hemorroides internas se clasifican según
su nivel de avance las hemorroides
internas de primer grado son aquellas
que siempre permanecen dentro del recto
las hemorroides internas de segundo
grado se expanden fuera del recto
durante la defecación y luego regresan
al interior del recto automáticamente
las hemorroides internas de tercer grado
se extienden fuera del recto durante la
defecación y luego deben ser empujadas
dentro del recto
las hemorroides internas de cuarto grado
siempre permanecen fuera del recto y no
pueden ser empujadas hacia adentro
antes de una hemorroide ctc o mia es
posible que reciba anestesia local o
general si recibe anestesia general
recibirá medicamentos para dormir a
través de una máscara de oxígeno o por
vía intravenosa se le insertará un tubo
respiratorio por la boca y en la tráquea
que le ayudará a respirar durante la
operación su cirujano empezará
utilizando un bisturí electro
cauterización o láser para hacer una
incisión en el tejido que rodea la
hemorroide para exponer la vena hinchada
su cirujano puede ligar la vena hinchada
para evitar que sangre cuando sea
extraída su cirujano extraerá la vena
hinchada y el tejido inflamado su herida
puede quedar abierta o su cirujano puede
suturar la finalmente su cirujano
colocará vendas medicadas sobre la
herida que le ayudarán a sanar y la
protegerán de infecciones
generalmente el procedimiento dura cerca
de una hora después de su procedimiento
se le retirará el tubo de respiración se
le ordenará consumir una dieta alta en
fibras y tomar mucho líquido para evitar
el estreñimiento durante su recuperación
que normalmente dura de dos semanas a
dos meses
o puede recomendar baños tibios
medicamentos o laxantes que le hagan
sentir más cómodo los días posteriores a
su procedimiento la mayoría de personas
pueden regresar a casa el día del
procedimiento pero algunas deben
permanecer en el hospital de 1 a 2 días
después de regresar a casa debe llamar a
su médico inmediatamente si tiene fiebre
dolor excesivo drenaje de la herida
enrojecimiento o hinchazón